hey everyone thanks for joining in
welcome to culture binge where we the
wisecrack crew feast on the zeitgeist
and lovingly regurgitate it for you
I'm your host Alec the managing editor
here at wisecrack I'm here with
researcher and annunciator in chief Suhr
be hey servi hi everyone and the
saltiest of the culture binge host but
not only in a physical sense the Maven
of moisture have I used that before
Michael Burns PhD everyone yay my I do
I'm a salty tasting guy it's just a
quick reminder we have and actually this
probably change from honest episode we
have one more episode in December and
then we're doing a little bit of a
season break and we back mid January
thank you all for listening in the
absence of bad sweat puns you could
always I don't know leave us a review on
Apple podcast wherever you're listening
that lets you leave reviews that'd be
super cool maybe you could come up with
new names for Michael Burns or survey
she needs names too you can find me
Jared and Ryan on the squanch
starting next week when we're Kamal
Reddy comes back there's a link to that
in the description but show itself we've
got a lot of cool stuff to talk about
today Michael is going to talk about the
okay boomer meme sir bees got a topic on
workplace tipping and I'm going to be
talking I'm going to be talking about
tick tock censorship but at that time
what's good what's bad what slaps what
chaps well usse our survey so what chaps
is that I think Trader Joe's has stopped
selling Toblerone chocolate and I'm
really gutted about it because I love
going to Trader Joe's and stress-eating
Toblerone
but what's laps is that Costco is
selling a six-pack of Toblerone during
the holidays so but so that's really
great news but the problem is that it's
a seasonal item so I need to stock up
for the rest of the year I've already
gone through three things are getting
critical but I'm surprised it's not like
a 50 pack on Costco that's what we
really need maybe maybe
we could start a public awareness
campaign yeah that's what I really need
all right
what well thank you peebo Blanc for
donating you Mike
okay here's what slaps what's laps is
this thing called couch tour which I
only learned about recently it involves
this website called nugs TV started by
an illegal live music tapir who turned
his illegal thing into an actual
business where they broadcast live
concerts from a lot of different bands
and there's a good amount of artists who
are on this service so you can basically
purchase to live watch really
high-quality live features from a band
you like and as I think I mentioned the
first time I was ever on here over the
summer I started to get into the
Grateful Dead and dedan company the new
version of the band that John Mayer is
in and they're doing a little New York
tour right now so last week I got to sit
on the couch with some friends we got
some really nice beers and snacks and
watched a really high-quality you know
two nights at Madison Square Garden all
while being lazy asses and it's it's fun
and I think if you're into live music
worth checking out if there's bands that
you're into that are on that because
it's the the lazy man or woman or
person's friend yeah I really like it
what chaps is how do i phrase this who
the increasing death of awesome media
websites about six weeks ago I would
wake up and you know do whatever I do in
the morning and normally two of the
first websites I'd look at where
splintery calm to look at some fun
snarky political and cultural news and
then I go to Deadspin dot-com to look at
some snarky sports and culture news
neither of those websites exist anymore
splinters dead and a dead spin is
functionally dead and it's sad to see
this trend of really cool media sources
dying off so that sucks and if for some
reason you're a good-hearted venture
capitalist buy something good and give
them complete editorial control
yeah the debts been paying I don't read
sports news but I was aware of their
existence it sucks that they're
essentially I mean they're gonna still
exist but it was three of all the
writers quit in the way that they did
and really
bosses [ __ ] that was kind of amusing
so so Deadspin two things happened the
this venture capital firm bought this
website the sports website and cut like
a deal with farmers insurance where they
had to deliver so many impressions but
couldn't meet that so they put these
really intrusive autoplay video ads on
that we're knowing the [ __ ] out of
everyone the writers wrote about this
saying like hey we're sorry like the
editorial has no control over these
terrible ads they should stop this that
got taken down and like a date later
Deadspin and all these sort of like
Gawker former Gawker web sites have like
different sections so one part was
called the concourse where you could see
the writers writing about political
stuff and then there was like other sort
of more pop culture things on there and
some of those stories like the only time
I'd ever intend upon dead spin was
stories about other stuff besides sports
and the management for seemingly
inexplicable reasons were like hey guys
stick to sports and all the editor quit
and then like immediately or in that
week like every single writer quit down
to the last writer where now all the
articles going up there which are not
that many are just put up by Deadspin
which is probably like some CEO trying
to blog so that's a fun story but yeah I
used to read Gawker every morning until
saying a guy named Peter Thiel funded a
lawsuit hogan and it shut them down and
since then I just really haven't checked
the news that often that's why Alex
out-of-touch we always have to tell him
about what happened in the past 18
months well the other one was Gothamist
which is New York News and they were
bought by WNYC so I read them again
Kaufman's awesome anyway for about you
sorry always saying how about you I feel
bad you intro all of ours and I didn't
want you to have to intro yourself in
this masturbatory way so I wanted you to
feel like you were set up so hey what
what chaps and slabs for you Alec I
really appreciate that this is a this is
a really nerdy one that I think is gonna
excite like five people listening I play
this game called gloom Haven it's like
one of the top ranked tabletop games
it's like D&D and a board game kinda
you build a character and it's called
it's a legacy game which means like it's
not just like one game and you're over
like you sort of like build stats that
carry over the next game it's really
awesome if you're in a nerdy [ __ ]
definitely check it out it's very
expensive but my friend bought it so
shout out to that friend for dishing out
$100 to this game
what chaps I'm gonna say I may be
running out of words that are related to
moisture and sweat so I'm really glad
we're having the season break so I could
kind of come back right like the the
Maven of moisture did I say that before
I don't even know I think that was no
okay well we got an email so if more
people could send me things to call you
that'd be really great
riot wild donate some money gloom Haven
for the win so thank you it's a sweet
game i-i've said before I've really
wanted to do a D&D game my friends keep
dragging their feet but this is like
filling that void for me anyway we're
gonna get into our topics we're gonna
talk about okay boomer before that I
have a little bit of a sponsor message I
want to thank our sponsor Mac Weldon
this week Mac Weldon makes smartly
designed men's basic like sure it's
hoodies underwear and more as someone
who's often overwhelmed when shopping
for clothes I really love their simple
shopping experience you want hoodie they
got one hoodie you want a button-up
shirt they've got one shirt obviously in
any color you like
it's simple designs with premium fabrics
I'm doing this thing where I'm trying
not to look like garbage all the time I
don't know if anyone's noticed but I'm
kind of upgrading my my clothes try not
to buy cheap garbage all the time and
what I really I like to keep things
simple I just wear black shirts all the
time and button ups and stuff like that
and their website is kind of great for
great for that so I ordered a few things
and I have to say I really love the
oxford shirt I'm wearing it right now
it's a button-up looks great yeah I
actually wore to a meeting where it was
important on a professional way that I
did not look like human garbage anyway
you're gonna love this Michael it's got
anti sweat technology super high-tech
not just wicking wicking I don't know
that might be old news by now the shirt
fabric is designed to keep you extra
cool and remove this
when it's in vapor stage instead of when
it condenses into actual liquid and
stains your shirt also you know if
that's not enough there's like a
stitching of an underarm sweat guard so
very into that I was running around
Manhattan ever mentioned meetings and it
definitely passed the alux wet test
maybe I just make fun of Michael because
I'm also truly sweaty I also got their
air knit t-shirts which are kind of like
a great shirt for working out they're
very comfortable very breathable and I
didn't look like a schnook which is
great I always thought well you know I'm
trying not to look like a schmuck
someone just telegrammed me it was Jacob
who said I look sexy so Thank You Jacob
Wow place compliments that's always good
that ends well you can get 20% off your
first order visit Mac well done comm I
think we have that up on the screen if
you're listening to this it's in the
description we got it everywhere so
enter promo code wisecrack for 20% off
again Mac Weldon comm promo code wise
crack that we can get into boomers well
can I say before we get into boomers
this is for any listener I have nothing
to do with advertising parts of this but
Mac Weldon to the underwear I wear
because they're the only ones that keep
my midsection cool on a steaming outside
so I I have a whole drawer full of them
and they have one of their like really
thin knit um boxer briefs or whatever oh
my god they were they were a
life-changer dimer the first day I put a
pair of those on went out on a hot day
and there was a coolness in my special
parts that has really been a game
changer so many people recommend Lisa
silver so it's antimicrobial so yeah it
naturally kills germs well since you
brought it up my butt smells bed and I
fart too much so my partner brought that
up and we got me silver boxer shorts
from then so I have a lot of problems
listeners and viewers and myself in
semi-soft so so thank you Mike that's my
new thing in 2020 I'm gonna be real
boxed in but for the rest of 2019
I'm an open book and but surpise a
germaphobe so I really want to know
what's going through her head but anyway
well actually I before we even started I
was going to compliment you on
you're sure that I really liked the
color in the cut of it it's very
flattering
yeah you look I mean I want to thank
Eric for donating attention the surbhi
mukbang funds I guess that that $2 is
going to the marketing fun maybe should
be tobor around although it should be I
don't know if I want to can you get
diabetes from one one session of the
young out yes boomers there's a meme
going around and it's just okay boomers
maybe there's comma in it maybe there's
not what's going on oh well no one is
more qualified to talk about this than
an old millennial like myself I am
officially a millennial okay Stan was
wondering but a senior one something
that popped off on the internet over I'd
say over the past couple weeks it's
gotten attention from olds and others is
this meme okay boomer and some of the
early instances or uses of this meme are
sort of like audio clips or images of
boomers and old people basically like
accusing Gen Z of having Peter Pan
syndrome and not growing up and not
taking their responsibilities seriously
enough and and sort of like desiring too
much for their futures and the Boomer
response is like you know I I paid for
my own college and did all this and
worked hard stop whining and because Gen
Z is rad and I truly think this like I
think that the younger generation is
very rad for a number of reasons we can
maybe get into their response has been a
casual two-word okay boomer to sort of
undercut the kind of cultural criticism
coming at them from the generation that
they might see as making their world a
terrible or creating the conditions that
it meant their lives are bad and there
was a New York Times piece about it they
interviewed a bunch of the people that
have both perpetuated this meme and made
merch around this meme one person made
10,000 dollars off hoodies and the first
day they went up but a bunch of the
young people they interviewed had really
smart takes and they were like you know
where the where the generation that has
the most downward mobility since like
World War two so yes we're pissed off
and were annoyed that the generation
that had some of the biggest cultural
and economic advantages arguing
[ __ ] go ahead Alec the the amazing thing
is I was like oh wow that kid made
$10,000 and there's like maybe a tinge
of jealousy but then when asked what
they were doing in this New York Times
article they're like oh it's gonna go to
my college yep which is like that's
one-fifth of one year maybe yeah and
that's the most Jen's II thing ever
right like you start to read that
article and you're maybe millennial or
Gen X or boomer brain is like oh they're
just making money off this because blah
blah blah they know they need money
paying for college don't judge them okay
what did what did the Boomers do they
sold I don't know jazz cigarettes to
help pay their $50 a semester college
fees or something sorry Oh old-timey
talk for marijuana joints and I'm pretty
sure there's like a super racist
connotation and why they were called
jazz cigarettes as well but it's a thing
that like they used to say real thing
didn't make that up so yeah and I think
when we could talk about all sides of
this the interesting thing that happened
with okay boomer is that Millennials
murdered it in like 48 hours just ripped
it apart and killed it and I want to
read a tweet and I can I liked retweet
this so anyone who follows me on Twitter
you can see this or follow me if you
don't I just it's great content every
day that's not true but a writer I'm
gonna say her her last name wrong and
Alec you might know this I'm Rachel sigh
me
sym II she's a new york-based writer
she's written a lot of features for like
The New Yorker New York Times writer who
I like a lot but I don't know how to say
her name if for any reason she listened
to this podcast
she probably doesn't think she should
I'm really sorry but she tweeted this a
couple days ago she said the reason okay
boomer is such a great generational
marker is it cleave so neatly boomers
hate it Gen X will mock it Millennials
will enthusiastically use it to the
point of exhaustion exhausting it
without actually inventing it and Gen Z
has already moved on and thinks we're
all noobs and then she followed up by
saying everyone I know who loves to say
it is like 33 which is kind of what
happened and one of the things that led
to this was write as okay boomer was
coming into cultural consciousness
former President Barack Obama scolded
people for getting mad on the internet
it's an event the other day
and and the the response from
Millennials was like - okay boomer
former President Barack Obama which just
felt corny on all sides and and the the
means that were made by Millennials kind
of killed it and I think it's a there's
two very interesting things here and
I'll say this and I'll stop talking on
the one end I think it's a great example
of how awesome Gen Z is we can talk
about this more but I truly think
they're great in a lot of ways I think
there's certain things you see them
doing in both like art and media and and
social movements that are things that
people didn't do when I was a teen and
in my early 20s so they're rad the
lamest thing I think is that Millennials
are so like self-hating that sometimes
all we want to do is appropriate like
younger culture and and we're not aware
that we're just murdering it so I think
my takeaway from all this for
Millennials is like just appreciate
things like it doesn't have to be about
you you can appreciate okay boomer
without having to be like oh they ran
out of quinoa my salad shop okay boomer
doesn't it doesn't matter just just just
appreciate that someone else said that
what do y'all think about okay boomer so
this is the first time I've ever heard
of this so I feel very much out of the
loop on this but I I don't know that I
don't know that I I don't feel like I
appropriate like younger culture I think
I do it ironically when I talk to my
younger cousins and I message them
things like what's goofy and like say
things like what's it like that's lit
and like like if somebody's like oh I
got like I'm gonna go to Paris in the
summer I'll be like that's a weird flex
but okay so like I try to like do that
but it's all very like they just think
I'm ridiculous because I don't speak
like that so I don't know that I do that
I don't know that my friends do that but
it's interesting that this is like a
cultural thing going on I don't really I
don't really know like okay boomer its
kind of
but I also think it's unkind because it
I think Alec you said it or somebody
said ated undercuts people and I don't I
meant that in a positive way oh you
meant in a positive way I think it's
called a bandit I'm a monster I sort of
feel like when we say things like that
it it trivializes other people and it
diminishes their experience and I don't
know that I I don't know that I'm okay
with that
so much yeah I think so I think I got
sick of this meme this morning when I
was reading about it but I was really
into it for the past two days I probably
helped kill it well I I didn't make an
okay broomer joke but I was like going
in my head of like what philosophy book
can I Photoshop out the title right okay
boomer get retweets I didn't come to a
conclusion however I think I'm a little
torn because first of all I I like the
spirit of a Boomer as like a mindset
this is kind of in the Taylor runs a New
York Times article it's like kind of
like anyone can exhibit boomer mentality
so like to me especially on the internet
like someone is a boomer in a specific
moment when they're like complaining
about Millennials killing TGI Fridays or
something like that in which case I'm
like okay boomer
that being said like I don't want to
like bracket all people from a certain
age range there because there are some
boomers who have done some pretty dope
stuff who have made some pretty dope
music is dope in the appropriating
cool-kid language I don't know but um
there there's that and also I read
there's a soften in the Guardian that
was kind of complaining that like so one
of my complaints about boomers is like
parent might my parents have like a
sweet deal my dad graduated college was
like buy time who's my age it was
already divorced twice or sorry divorced
once married twice had two kids had a
job with a single single income was able
to buy a house and all this stuff and
there was a moment where he was like oh
you got damn Millennials I mean my
brother just made fun of him so much in
person then I think he gave that up and
was like oh I get it like
we ruined the economy everything's Fox
and now he doesn't do that anymore which
I think it's something you do in person
with somebody but doesn't necessarily
work on the Internet where people just
get like automatically very defensive
another thing this happened the the
Guardian was talking about how perfectly
for circumstances that they may or may
not have created but like we're tyring
boomers now are like [ __ ] like a huge
percentage of them have like less than
$25,000 in savings they won't be able to
live off of Social Security just like
all of these terrible economic
conditions and then it gets a little
trickier because it's like you know our
boomers the victims of themselves are
they a victim of a subset of boomers or
like you know the like vulture
capitalists who gutted all these things
and left us with a terrible future and
so that was that this writers argument
which I'm certainly sympathetic to and
so like I don't like I do think it's
funny when boomers the same boomers who
complain about Millennials and Gen Z
being snowflakes like how dare you say
that that's ageist although I don't like
I think some people are using it like
it's just a way to say old people which
like I'm not because you know people get
screwed over we shouldn't use them that
way we should just use it as like a
collective group of people who did a
thing has nothing to it their age it
just has to do with like the moment that
they grew up in in the same way we can
say like Americans did X Y or Z and
obviously not all Americans did those
things but like as a country we voted
for that person or went to war with that
country or passed this legislation you
know yeah well this is why the grammar
is important as well because the main
meme isn't okay boomers it's not saying
like screw a whole age bracket of people
it's used to say okay boomer normally at
a specific boomer that's exemplifying
the toxic ideology of boomer ISM because
there was a LA Times article and I
forgot the the name of the writers and
op-ed I think it came out yesterday or
the day before but it brought up like
you know there's people that are super
old that by the logic of Gen Z are doing
cool stuff like Jane Fonda getting
arrested every day with her friends like
that's not boomer behavior that's like
something that's cool and she's I think
Jane Fonda isn't relate
these early 80s so I think it's not as
much tied to age as two people embodying
a certain form of cultural logic which
tends to like place blame or speak down
to people and Gen Z how would you define
that logic I think that's kind of an
interesting question because I have my
own but I want I mean I think part of it
is like a logic of a like so and this is
I didn't think about this before so this
is trash I'm sorry listeners but part of
it is AG illogic of self-sufficiency a
lot of it comes down to like we did X on
our own why can't you do that
and then I think a lot of it is a one
writer use the term Peter Pan syndrome
Gen Z
wanting a lot in life and kind of having
a more idealistic bordering on utopian
vision of what they want the world or
art occult or whatever to look like and
then then being told they're not allowed
to think like that almost like that
they're not allowed to dream big or
dream seriously in the same way like you
know Gen Z will say this is [ __ ] we come
out of college with a ton of debt we
can't afford to then get a house because
the job market sucks and then their
parents or grandparents tell them the
narrative about how they graduated
without debt got a job were married at
26 and we're paying off their mortgage
who are you to complain so no those are
like the the functions of that critique
that seemed to be the ones that they're
responding to you're shaking your head a
lot servers so you can because I so I
think I misunderstood the original
intent of this like phrase okay boomer
so for me I thought it was like a way to
like be unkind to boomers but I think no
sense it's like a way to like respond
yeah and yeah I'm sorry that makes me so
angry because I hear a lot about this
and my family where people will be like
oh these Millennials they come in and
after year they want a a new job or they
want a raise or like all this stuff and
it's like well why not we see how [ __ ]
over you got by not asking for a raise
by not like committing to career
development and growth like should we do
the same thing and week
grow up in an economy where we didn't
have as many opportunities where we
weren't able to have like a single
income and get a job and when people say
things about Peter Pan syndrome well a
lot of people live at home because they
can't afford anything else so that makes
me mad too when people say like when I
was your age I was married and had kids
well when you were my age you also
probably didn't have a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars in debt unable to
afford a house so that makes me really
mad and I I don't like that I think it's
a it's a lack of understanding and
empathy on the part of an older
generation that doesn't understand what
younger generations go through so I
think Millennials are caught in this
this phase where it's like we constantly
have to defend ourselves and fight for
things and the generation after us sees
what we're going through and they're
just I feel like some of my younger
cousins are jaded by it they're like oh
like our parents are like weird and then
our older cousins are they're just seem
bitter and angry and part of me is
bitter and angry yeah it's interesting
that so the boomers for a time labeled
by I guess the greatest generation I
don't know the technical generation name
they were called the me generation
because they're a bunch of narcissists
like they're the generation that was
like great like let's get really into
Wall Street and cocaine and like you
know gild everything in gold and so now
they're kind of projecting that on us
because we want like health insurance
and also like to me the the boomer
mindset it's it's a lot of like their
eyes are pretty cool like you know
economic opportunities housing all this
stuff for time the medical system was
not as screwed up as it is or was at
least partially better and so I think
they just universalize it's kind of like
in a narcissistic way that like oh yeah
well like this is the way I did it and
like I work so hard because I'm so
special like why aren't these kids and
I'll just an anonymous boomer that I
know
all named names but they're playing when
they retire and I think this is just a
beautiful encapsulation of this they're
like they want to kind of keep working
to keep themselves busy and there they
want to just go into a radio station and
just volunteer to like read the news of
the Morning News and so in their mind
they could just like walk into radio
station and be like hello I'd like a job
please can I do your most important job
like once a day for free and I think it
just speaks to like that was probably
their experience after graduating to
college is like I have a degree I'd like
a job please yes thank you very much and
then I think that all kind of like
trickles down into how they view the
supposedly like entitled Millennials oh
yeah yeah and I think like going off
that example is real quick I didn't
think about like my my dad who was a
Boomer he had that whole [ __ ] where like
he ended up in a good career but it was
like well my uncle got me a job in the
mailroom at the company and then I
slowly worked my way up and I was like a
real thing we're getting the lowest paid
job and like a company he ended up
getting a really high paying job later
in life and like that's not a thing but
it used to truly be a thing for people
now if for entry-level jobs you still
need two years of experience yeah yeah I
got $1,000 in debt to get an unpaid
internship mm-hm
to do for two years before I'd have
enough experience to have a job that
pays me $30,000 a year I don't like
anything at all well on that downer I
think we should I think we should move
on sir B you want to talk about bosses
bosses developing relationships with
people
exciting topic so over the weekend
McDonald's chief executive Steve
Easterbrook was fired for having a
consensual relationship with a
McDonald's employee the Board determined
that Easterbrook had engaged in a
relationship that violated company
policy which prohibits employees from
having a direct or indirect reporting
relationship from dating or having a
sexual relationship
so in Easterbrook's case because he was
the chief executive
means anyone who worked at McDonald's
employment lawyers' have stated that his
firing signals changing attitudes about
romance in the workplace so this topic
can become quickly heated and I don't
want to focus on whether McDonald's was
correct and firing its CEO but what I do
want to chat about is how you feel about
workplace romances in general and
whether or not they should be prohibited
well I thought about this a little bit I
when I was in college dated a co-worker
it was not their boss and we've been
together for eight years coming in a few
days well that story have fun ending so
but I in my mind like there are like I
kind of support the idea that they're a
bad idea that obviously corporations
need to like discourage them like a high
cost at the same time like I'm not
sitting around being like you dated a
co-worker you must be a monster although
because I think what happens is for
every time that like let's say the CEO
JIT Amit Lee falls in love with you know
someone who works there and there's not
like weird coercion and it's just really
a beautiful relationship maybe I don't
know that relationship there's probably
ten cases of like bosses being creepers
and using their position of power to get
someone to go on a date with them or
something like that so like I don't want
to point fingers at the McDonald's
person because I don't know the scenario
but I get like on a policy level why
that's true and I think it's always been
that and also not to mention most
relationships and in people breaking up
and that's got to be super awkward for
all kinds of other reasons yeah I mean I
think the point you made about the for
everyone you know well-intentioned
workplace relationship there's 10 or
more that are shady and abuses of power
I think is the the important thing and I
always think about I spent you know
about a decade in academia at various
levels is like a gratitude and a
part-time worker and a full-time worker
and man I saw some shady [ __ ] over the
year
of people taking advantage of their
power and influence as an academic
almost exclusively males I only ever
knew one woman professor who did some
shady [ __ ] although it was pretty well
that's a story for when we're off air
but or just you DM me I'll tell it to I
don't care I'm sloppy but you know I saw
a lot of this and it's it's not good and
like the effects of normally it tends to
be a man in power having feelings for a
woman who tends to be younger in a
lower-ranking position it creates a lot
of tensions and creates you brought up
the breakup thing
um creates a really shitty situation for
the person who's lower down in the power
dynamics whether that's a man or woman
or whoever because you're in this really
awkward scenario where someone that
you've been romantically entangled with
and vulnerable with now has power over
the means of your like existence and
your you know ability to pay rent and
stuff and in my devil's advocate would
be I don't know we work more than ever
some people are at their jobs 60 80 80
hours a week where else do you meet
people so like I have I have sympathy
for the fact that some people are so
immense in that world that like you do
it and like I don't know I I have a
friend
we'll call him not Michael who works at
a creative startup and when it's like a
small place and people hang out all the
time you see people have in flirtations
or romantic stuff but it's almost like I
get it you people are a bunch of young
people around the same age you're
together all the time that's bound to
happen to me it seems like we might need
new ways of thinking about the morality
and ethics of this and sort of formal
things like do we know for example what
the McDonald's code of conduct was it
was broken
exactly no no information has been
provided there's almost certainly a
policy against having relationships with
like a subordinate yeah well that was
the one that I read you can't have a
director in direct reporting
relationship don't know what if one of
y'all met someone at work who happened
to be your subordinate and you truly
truly had like a special connection with
them would you avoid that would you like
for me like I thought about this a lot
because I've been involved with a few
like in previous positions I've been
involved with people I've worked with
but none of them have been like my
direct superior my direct manager or
anybody within my line of management but
I think I think like peer-to-peer
relationships are fine like I don't
think that you need to disclose those
sorts of things but if it is somebody
within like tangentially related like in
your department or something who's in a
senior leadership role I do think that
that should be disclosed not to ask for
permission but maybe to just say like
this is what's going on so if we are
working on a product together if this
person is involved in like my review
cycle or something like that you should
be aware of it to remove any conflict of
interest but if it's somebody like the
CE o our CEO or somebody like that who
has like strong who has a strong
influencing power over your career I
don't think that they should be allowed
to have relationships with subordinates
yeah even the way it starts is so like
what you say wholesomely a boss is like
want to go on a date that person is
probably gonna be like well I maybe get
a promotion if I not get promoted if I
you know like and as soon as that
happens and this happens in academia all
the time there was it wasn't even a
romantic relationship but there was this
big [ __ ] show of this philosopher named
avi tal Rennell are you familiar with
this oh boy yes yeah she I don't know if
she one of her grad students who's a gay
man and I think she is she straight her
she lesbian anyway there was like a lot
of like like sexual joking where they
like jokingly cuddle but after a while
he's like I don't want to jokingly
cuddle you anymore and then launch this
whole big like sexual harassment thing
but yeah it's just all this sort of like
disconnects where it's probably a
horrible idea although again I'm gonna
throw myself under the bus before I
dated my coworker so I was all right
we were both arias I was not her boss
I dated a resident and I like to say I
was pretty impartial and also she is the
one who asked me out not vice versa but
I would write her friends up a night and
give a [ __ ] so I would also write up my
friends up because we like listen if you
can't put a tie on the door you deserve
to put a snitch like wow I just I saw
the door like come on oh but I mean I
think there's a good tie in
yeah there's a good tie in from the last
topic to this of course because like
what did boomer culture establish as
appropriate workplace relationships like
sketchy [ __ ] like I I'm the product of a
sketchy workplace relationship yes
viewers and listeners that makes you now
think I'm trash and you should never
listen to me I shouldn't exist but I'm
here because yeah but my oh [ __ ] you're
right backing away from it no but my I
mean I don't know there it I one of
these people isn't alive one of them
would never listen to this or watch this
because she's bad at the computer but my
parents met in a setting where my mom
was like a secretary in an office and my
dad was someone that like worked in this
office not directly with her and they
got like shit-faced on st. Patrick's Day
and hooked up this is too real I'm
getting way vulnerable in 2020 I'm not
saying anything but like that was just
like normal and they would tell that
story about how they met like that's a
good normal thing whereas in 2019 that
would seem just wild or at least would
seem inappropriate so I think there is
an established workplace culture and
people from that generation are still at
the top of the corporate ladder and
haven't caught up to how suspect a lot
of this behaviour can I just say I love
that it was also on your hallowed Irish
holiday of Saint Patrick's Day
it makes it a little bit a little bit
better yeah it was on a school bus bar
crawl in the south side of Chicago just
dirtbag early all around this makes
sense to anyone of why yeah why I'm a
sweaty piece of garbage I will say that
if you engage in a workplace
relationship be very careful
if you break up things can get very
awkward oh yeah why do you think I don't
never mind I did not break up during
that tenure and yeah anyway I've got a
topic today it's about tick-tock
so tick-tock you know it's a nap the
kids are on the Zoomers if you will they
make memes about okay boomers etc um
it's owned by a Chinese company called
byte dance and there was an article and
I believe it's in description on
Politico talking kind of rounding up the
kind of evidence about them censoring
stuff so Chinese censorship has become
an issue when the NBA which has a very
large presence in China one of the
general managers tweets a pro Hong Kong
tweet the NBA freaks out the Chinese
government's not happy all that stuff in
this context the Soulja story from the
article so according to documents
obtained by the Guardian tik-tok
censored numerous subjects that extend
beyond the obvious topic seem dangerous
to the Chinese state according to the
Guardians reporting on the directives in
the documents tik-tok suppress videos
about quote a specific list of 20
foreign leaders or sensitive figures
including Kim jong-il Kim il-sung
Mahatma Ghandi Vladimir Putin Donald
Trump Barack Obama Kim jong-un and
Shinzo ABI and quote think of how much
social media vitriol is jeri by figures
on that list and it's easy to understand
why fun app would be one why a fun app
would want to blacklist those
politically divisive figures then it
goes on after these documents were
revealed the company issued a statement
denying it continues its previous
policies quote let us be very clear the
company said tik-tok does not remove
content based on sensitivities really
China we have never been asked by the
Chinese government to remove any contact
cut content and we would not do so if
asked period our us moderation team
which is let out of California reviews
content for adherence to our US policies
just like other US companies in our
space
we're not influenced by any foreign
government including the Chinese
government still people aren't buying it
so one of the things they might do is
it's called shadow banning where
if you make kind of like a political
tick-tock it'll be on your page maybe
your friends can see it but we're not
get distributed widely and also this it
applies to not just stuff about you know
Chinese figures or stuff related to
Chinese politics but kind of all
political content which someone told me
they kind of likes because tick tock is
a place to tell and why not a place to
get stressed out about politics but you
know obviously that can get very sketchy
very quickly yeah what do you guys think
I'm interested in knowing more about who
tick tocks investors are and where they
get their money and whether they have
any foreign investment from China
because they could have like oh we're
not influenced but at the same time our
VC is from China
wait isn't any Chinese company okay yeah
but but maybe they have international
investors I don't know yeah oh there you
go
I I don't know like when I hear about
things like censorship and stuff like
this I'm never surprised and I'm always
surprised when other people are
surprised because I'm like what do you
mean how are you surprised right now
yeah no I mean I think to to tie back to
my my chat thing from earlier like I
don't know there's on a much smaller
example clearly though the web sites I
mentioned before splintering Deadspin
got shut down because the investors and
those things didn't like the political
and cultural overtones of what they were
saying it seems clear in this case as
well and I don't know I just I can't not
be bummed about any type of censorship
even if and I think you said that a
friend mentioned this Alec I totally get
that you might just want to watch fun
videos on tick-tock of like teens doing
the meme where they like do things from
history class to rap music
god I feel old and not have like
politics coming at you but every form of
media I'm gonna make a blanket statement
has always been able to be used for
political subversion and activism and
exploration and I think it's a it's a
weird precedent as we move towards you
know the world
20:22 be censoring any sort of political
speech on a social media platform it
just feels icky the thing that I'm kind
of I don't really have any answers but
I've been thinking about it so this is
bad obviously state censorship
especially bad I guess in the back of my
head I'm just curious if like China's
being scapegoated and kind of like a
weird way and they're not apples to
apples but as you mentioned like you
know sites like Deadspin are being
censored by their hedge fund managers
like this happens a little odd news and
a lot of literature written about how
advertiser interests often effectively
create censorship on cable news which is
icky state censorship feels icky er but
like I don't know like I'm open to sort
of interrogate that and the other thing
is like America has been exporting their
culture you know since at least world
war ii if not earlier where wherever you
are you're probably consuming us
American music American movies sometimes
American news we had the voice of
America which was essentially like a
like a propaganda arm setting up radio
stations to tell people about how great
democracy was and you know other so
we're kind of dealing with the other end
of the stick now where it's not mulcher
but it's like another country's
technology is coming in sort of shaping
the public debate and granted it still
feels icky er because when it's like
u.s. music being exported it's like well
you know there's our private individuals
private companies whatever it's not you
know Ronald Reagan or Bill Clinton
saying what gets to make it on there
unless this voice America I don't really
know the oversight structure but yeah I
mean the technology thing the way that a
foreign government can like you know
tick-tock out find a ton of money for
violating like privacy rights for
children and under US law it just it
feels icky but I also want to be aware
of the way that like sometimes we happen
to put extra special attention on a
country that happens to have
geopolitical tensions with America and
put a standard like put them under a
microscope that they were not on there
otherwise be under and I don't think
that means that we should say China's
great nothing bad Bad's happening there
or that we shouldn't talk about these
things but I'm just saying it gets
tricky no I think you're totally right
that the
kind of easy response here's to do some
weird blame China thing which I think is
yet not even short-sighted to act like
it's a uniquely geopolitical problem
that only applies to to Chinese business
interest and that America's this
wonderful place that would never do
anything to of squanch free speech so
yeah a good point you say Squatch free
speech I did I was looking for another
word and then I think I was just like
you know what let's do some brand
synergy product tie-in because now
listeners the word squatches in their
head and then later they're gonna want
to listen to the squadron i also want to
give a shout out Thank You Rohan who
just wants sports anyway thank you Ron
sir be anything else dad and keep it
short one yeah I don't have too much to
add to this topic okay all right let's
get into the voicemails we got some
voicemails we got some emails if you
want to leave us a voicemail the numbers
one two one three five three four eight
eight zero seven that's one two one
three five three four eight eight oh
seven and email us at culture binge at
wisecracks Co anyway what's what's the
first voicemail we got oh we just got
one it's from Roberto and we're gonna
listen to it and then we have some some
paper emails Alec looks concerned did I
do something wrong I thought we had two
voices okay
I'll make one up if you want but let's
start with the real one before I make
one up hey wise correct my name is
Roberto I'm calling on behalf of culture
avenged episode 19 where surbhi talks
about talking to soldiers about opiate
addiction and Sesame Street coming from
a sociologist point of view we have a
lot of knowledge that children
internalize these ideas about addiction
and the toxic effects that it can have
for example we have this book written by
across villages called Matthew Desmond
called the victor that talks about the
eviction cycle and how that creates an
effect on children particularly in the
developmental stages we also know that
you know
children developmental disorders or
mental illnesses because of the cycle of
poverty and eviction and bringing that
to Sesame Street I think that Sesame
Street providing a safe and consumable
language where children can learn to
interpret these sorts of things can try
to at least provide the first effects of
mitigating the effect that opiate
addiction might have on the lives of
these children so just like to get
y'all's of thoughts appreciate it love
you Cheryl
bye that was that makes sense
I think that makes sense like if
children have like a baseline foundation
to understand what's going on so they're
not like I think children when they
don't understand things that can become
afraid and feel insecure and that can
lead to more issues so if Sesame Street
can provide a foundation on which
children can understand and they're not
afraid at first and then that could help
parents and other caregivers have more
extensive conversations I think that's
great I didn't think about that yeah
yeah I really liked that email I think
joy may avoided another voicemail on to
your device maybe it was me maybe it was
the best producer in the game joy I
don't know let's not assign blame and
praise somehow we have another email
voicemail it's from Ricky Joy's also the
best here we go
hey this is Ricky and I was listening to
the culture binge episode specifically
on the new feature on Netflix that's
gonna come to mobile where you can speed
up and slow down the playback speed of
the foot of your shows in your film I'm
actually excited for this and I'm
actually not excited for the feet up
part I'm actually excited for the slow
down part and that's because I'm a film
student myself particularly an animation
student and something that I like to do
to further my study within animation is
to slow down some footage to see it
better frame by frame now I know that I
can buy digital copies of these films to
like or maybe even like
legally download it to like you know
girlfriend back brain in my own life
media player application wherever that
may be but sometimes having the mobile
option just going through like quick
research on my phone on my iPad I think
it gives me more often to like have more
films that might be either harder to
acquire or that I still want to go
through the trouble like paying for
everything for it especially like favor
individual things if like Netflix can
provide for me provide me that yeah like
that's that another sort of an
alternative benefit to this Netflix new
Netflix feature is cool that's a good
point i didn't think we we I think am I
wrong in thinking we only discussed the
speed up function and one buddy might
have mentioned and maybe was an email so
I think sir like yeah but we might have
mentioned like for like people learning
English or any language like slowing it
down so you understand it which I need
the [ __ ] out of for Spanish because they
talk very fast that was a cool point
those we were talking about you know
like Judd Apatow and others who were
like we're filmmakers and speeding it up
will ruin our art but Ricky's point
there is like for people that really
appreciate film are studying things like
animation slowing down does the opposite
allows them to appreciate the art and
learn more so that's a really cool
perspective on that I I had one when I
was in his voice about one other
realization which is that uh a lot of
times like the the moments between lines
will be facial expressions and stuff
like that if you're someone like who
doesn't under get facial expressions
that well because you're on the spectrum
you don't get two shits and like of
course you want to X that so also [ __ ]
Judd Apatow for hating autistic people
Wow you heard it here folks Judd Apatow
hates autistic people sourced by Alec
spread the news I really wish him no ill
so with that being said that was a cool
voice man that was really thank you so
much what do we got on the emails oh boy
oh boy
firsts from Danny says hi all Michael
asked a couple weeks ago for anyone with
kids who aren't dicks how they taught
them compassion when last week's episode
came out and no one had responded
figured I probably should I'm a single
dad for ten years with primary custody
my 12 year old son he's a very kind and
considerate kid I could tell you about
how I've always been open and honest
whenever he's had questions how the
daycare center that he spent every week
Dan from 3:00 until 6:00 was very
ethnically diverse or how I'm open about
my own failings and vulnerabilities with
him but that might be beside the point I
asked him yesterday how he got to be so
kind and understanding of other kids he
told me it wasn't anything that I taught
him specifically he said he got that
from seeing the way how I interact with
other people well I think there are a
lot of ways to teach your kids empathy I
think it'll be difficult to make it
stick if you aren't a caring person
yourself kids are so freakin absorbent
of the behavior of the people they look
up to if we want more compassion to
children then we need to lead by example
thanks guys I appreciate every bit of
content y'all are putting out on the
Internet and something something sir be
mukbang from Danny that I almost teared
up reading that I'm not like kidding
sometimes when I say earnest stuff I
sound sarcastic that's like that's like
really sweet that is kids straight-up
said to him like dad the reason I'm good
is because of you I really like this
email I read it as I was like winding
down like relaxing before bad and I felt
very emotional too about it it was so
kind and it's so true children are like
sponges and so we set a good example
they'll follow it it makes me worried
because if I ever have kids
III veer towards sarcastic and so maybe
that's not the greatest you know
attribute so donate now anyone listening
hashtag Alec vasectomy and we'll make
sure that whenever it happens all funds
will go directly to a doctor I saw on a
billboard outside of Houston that said
he's done 15 million vasectomies
it's a real feel like that's true no
it's definitely true someone someone
who's listening this will know the
Billboard I'm talking about they're all
over the southeast and they update the
number and it's some creepy looking guy
and it's like dr. whatever has done X
million vasectomies and he's like it's
like well you've cut a lot of wiener
tubes so the next email was anyone have
any other thoughts on Danny's email yeah
sounds like a rad dad so if you need
father advice find Danny
next one's from Ricardo hi wisecrack
crew I'm Ricardo from Brazil and even
though I'm pretty a pretty consistent
listener I couldn't think of a better
instance of the show to mail on than
this one since I've always wanted to
send my DNA for a private company in
exchange for information I could gather
from communicating with my family I
absolutely love daylight savings time
because of the existing school college
work and seeing the Sun thing and every
single YouTube video I watched is locked
at two times speed so much so that I
find it really odd whenever watching
stuff like music or movie trailers
properly wow we were on brand for him to
be better suited to one topic I'll
comment more on the Netflix and content
speed option by saying that I'm very
much positive to it I find it really
annoying whenever watching some series
and the characters take like two seconds
between every line that's how he wrote
it out that wasn't me interpreting and
although there's an argument to be made
in favor of the writers intent with the
timing of everything I'd be much more
interested in just speeding up some
boring parts than to be fiddling with
the DoubleTap to skip 10 seconds and end
up having to manually find the start of
a line and wasting more time that waste
by just watching the thing also I would
like to thank you for the gruesome image
of me being the most efficient youtube
moneymaker after the content comment
about companies wanting the speeding up
of content therefore speeding up the
delivery of ads since I'm one of the few
people I know who doesn't run an ad
blocker on the site once again I
appreciate what you guys do greetings
from Brazil and keep up the good work
guys awesome yeah that was a great email
I don't have a ton I'll stab a thank you
should we call that a hat-trick episode
if we had three topics that were all
direct interest to Ricardo we call it
like some sort of a hat-trick or
something else maybe someone could
suggest a better name Oh a Ricardo trick
Oh a Rick Rick Rick Rick Rick loving
that I so I finally got ahold of
somebody's Netflix login able to watch
that very excited shout out to my aunt I
have been watching some other stuff too
and including The Handmaid's Tale which
is good but very slow so slow it moves
backwards so I've been skipping through
a lot of stuff and I do think about this
and wished very intensely that I had
like a one and a half or two times speed
option I think I want to rewatch
Dragonball Z on 10x speed because that's
how little happens in that show but I
need to know what happens because I went
away to summer camp in the middle of the
frieza saga and I came back and they
started again with like one of the
earlier episodes I wasn't gonna wait
around for that so now I just don't know
what happens and I'm gonna take acid and
watch stranger things on 20x speed and
see if I survive someone asked about the
email again just a reminder its culture
binge at wisecrack dot CEO sent us an
email yeah also a true story once some
people I knew in England were like hey
do you want to come over we're gonna
take acid and watch strange things and I
was like what a terrible idea
you're gonna acid in a show where
there's monsters in the walls
no they're they're idiots and you know
what there's a small chance some of them
are listening to this this is true and
if you're listening you're an idiot yeah
no you know in England they're they're
free Austin Smith who's a host of
various wisecrack properties once he and
I'm we both lived in Scotland got a
little drunk and and made this deal that
we're gonna go get free vasectomies from
the national healthcare system and we
were like my mid-20s didn't do it
we got another email should we get into
it yeah this is from anonymous I think
it's from the anonymous right like the
hacking organization okay that's our
name we're just we're just uh
you've an okay an email from an
anonymous person hi big fan of all
wisecrack content please keep up to
awesome work I'm an attorney and I
wanted to write in on your conversation
regarding DNA testing kits this is not
an area of the law I'm familiar with and
your discussion encouraged me to look
into the legal protections surrounding
our DNA and I was surprised and how
unregulated the industry is for example
HIPAA protects health information
including identifiable genetic
information by limiting its use and
disclosure however DNA services like
ancestry.com are not considered
healthcare providers or business
associates of health care providers and
are thus not required to follow HIPAA
guidelines this is just one example an
US federal law has simply not caught up
to this issue although some states are
moving to provide protection for DNA
anyways probably better to keep your DNA
away from these services also Serbia's
for travel recommendations for Vienna I
would like to recommend the I'm not
gonna be able to say this word kunst
history
oh boy why did I have to read this a
German word Kunz serious Museum which
has a spectacular collection of art
antiquities and sculpture but lack to
the crowds at other museums like the
Louvre it is one of the best museums I
have seen and was a highlight of my trip
to Vienna
thanks anonymous and sorry for the
pronunciation I think it's couldn't his
story shifts but I think it means
culture his ultra History Museum I only
took one semester of German I probably
[ __ ] that up so sorry it was the high
organisation anyway yeah so HIPAA the
word it's uh it's the the Privacy Act
for health care it stands for I think
health I'm gonna [ __ ] this up because
now nobody knows what it actually stands
for healthcare information Portability
and Protection Accountability Act or
something like that
I only know that because I had to get
HIPAA certified and that was one of the
questions and I've since forgotten as
many years ago I really liked this email
somehow I missed it in my inbox so I'm
super excited to read it and thank you
for the Vienna recommendation I'm so
excited about my trip yeah that's that's
like really cool that he he or she they
um hit us up about this and I think it's
it's also very terrifying and some like
slightly black mirror Eska way that
there's legal loopholes that mean that
companies like that don't have to follow
ethical standards in terms of what they
do with our DNA information and that
that truly freaks me out a little bit
yeah and so for more like whenever you
go to any doctor psychiatrist whatever
in a medical setting if you get a DNA
test genetic testing if you get a
vasectomy all that is like highly highly
regulated in the ways that they can use
it you sound a waiver probably and
everything that you never read none of
that applies to when you go on like you
know DNA and me calm or something like
that um and they can sell how they want
they can use it how they want if it
leaks and gets out there that's kind of
like fair game so yeah it's a [ __ ] show
Wow not good
cool well with that being said we will
see you all in December I believe so
thank you all so much for listening
don't forget Mac Weldon check their
stuff out promo code wisecrack it's
keeping keeping uh Bertha's nether
regions nice and cool probably truly
have them on right now and I feel
fantastic no exaggeration not doing this
for for freebies although if they need a
sweaty sweat wicking under remodel I
would be completely interested please
call me yeah so in the meantime if you
miss us you can follow us on twitter at
michael burns at SRI patel 22 at
wisecrack Alec that's me
you could leave us a review say nice
things and say some mean things even if
it's five star or leaves five stars then
say mean things we care about the stars
I'm just kidding don't do that please
but yeah thank you so much
[Music]